c'est simple en 2015 chaque foyer
français a mangé un kilo de fromage à
raclette
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu
un plat facile et rapide à réaliser car
il est loin le temps où la raquette
était le privilège des montagnards très
loin ne laissez ramollir jeu n'ont pas
de dire et quand il est suffisamment que
va sortir d'où le mot raclette dans la
sienne à consommer des cornichons des
petits oignons cornichons des petits
oignons des pommes vapeur
une recette qui donne envie et dès les
années 1970 tout le monde peut la faire
avec les premiers four à raclette
commercialisable comme ici au salon des
arts ménagers de 1976 connaissez-vous le
four à raclette ou comment obtenir grâce
aux infrarouges un délicieux fromages
fondus du valais mais qu'est ce qu'un
appareil à raclette sans son fromage
dans les années 1990 le fromage
s'industrialise un fromage pasteurisé
qui se conservent plus longtemps alors
en usine pour satisfaire tout le monde
il faut mettre les bouchées doubles pas
moins d'une centaine d'opérations
manipulation comprise effectués dans
quinze mille mètres carrés et 125
salariés pour que le lait se transforme
en fromage
une fois cahier il est pressé et passe
dans un vin de saumur
la plupart des opérations se font d'une
manière automatique
avant d'arriver dans les immenses cave
ou là le fromage change de couleur en
huit semaines d'affinage le fromage
s'adapte même aux appareils à raclette
le principe c'est d'avoir donc un
fromage tout en longueur dont la section
correspondent exactement à la taille des
poils ont découpé beaucoup plus
facilement
ce n'est plus une corvée soit bien
plaisir hein ça rentre parfaitement dans
tous les pôles ont des appareils à
quelqu'un retrouve dans commerce
la raclette c'est un plaisir un plaisir
qui est aussi un business est un
véritable marche économique 250 millions
d'euros en 2015
[Musique]